i i have a quote here about the many
worlds interpretation this is hardly the
most economical view
the most economical of viewpoints but my
own personal objections don't spring
from its lack of economy and
in particular i don't see why a
conscious being need be
aware of only one of the alternatives in
a linear superposition
what is it about consciousness that
demands that one cannot be aware
of the tantalizing linear combination of
being both dead and alive
it seems to me that a theory of
consciousness will be needed before
the many worlds viewed can be squared
with what one actually observes
so what do you think about this yeah i
think that that is
a um a an understandable objection but i
think
like an objection that is met by the
mathematics
um so what i mean is okay let's say you
have a
object that's in a superposition in many
worlds uh like so it's in two different
worlds
um it can only experience
like so let's say it's not a conscious
thing it's just a let's say an atom
um it can only experience all of the
other
objects in its world in that in the
state that they are in that world
so like in this state like so let's say
in this world
all of the objects are in state zero and
in that world they're all in state one
if you take one of the atoms inside of
here and you get it to measure one of
its partners
it will say that its partner is zero or
here
if you got it to measure its partner it
would say it's one it can only
experience that world
like with all of the things that are in
that world
as they are like you know um in that
state and so
let's say now i'm a conscious being and
i'm inside of
like both of these branches um i've just
done a measurement
of my um of my atom and uh
my atom is now like in state zero
according to in this branch
and in state one according to that
branch if i was to if i was able to
experience both
then i should be able to see the atom
being in state zero
and in state one but because of
how many worlds works how the
mathematics works out there is no
measurement that i can do inside of this
world
that would show me the result one it
would only say zero
and in that world i would only say one
and so there's no like i don't
experience the other world to me just
doesn't exist there's no evidence of it
anywhere
so of course i don't consciously
experience it